[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute bin ich nicht
irgendwo sondern in einer anderen küche
ich befinde mich gerade in der küche von
meiner schwiegermutter also von hamms
mama und es hat auch einen grund denn
ich habe euch ein bisschen verrückt
gemacht auf instagram ist tut mir leid
denn ich habe euch jetzt ein richtig
leckeres gericht aus hähnchen und
joghurt in allem was dazu gehört das
zeige ich euch gleich habe es euch über
instagram gezeigt und ich hab das rezept
nicht abgefilmt und ihr habt alle
gefragt und dann habe ich mir gedacht
wisst ihr was es ist zwar schon komplett
durchgeplant die ramadan reihe
aber dieses rezept das kommt auf jeden
fall noch und deswegen stehe ich hier
gerade und filme das wo ich ab und das
rezept habe ich natürlich auch von
meiner schwiegermama ich zeige euch
jetzt zuallererst das was sie für das
hähnchen benötigen wir benötigen ein
hähnchen was bereits gewaschen wurde und
die innereien sind auch schon raus an
gewürzen benötigen wir salz pfeffer
gemahlenen kreuzkümmel curry sind
gemeinden ingwer und gemeinden merken
außerdem benötigen wir eine ganze
zwiebel etwas essig und neutrales öl so
ihr lieben ich bin jetzt gerade darüber
zum herd und habe hier schon einen topf
bereits gelegt dass es ein tiefer topf
mit etwa einem liter wasser drin ließen
aber gleich wahrscheinlich noch was nach
und das erste was wir machen ist dass
wir in das wasser jetzt unsere ganzen
gewürze inklusive essig und öl geben
[Musik]
und jetzt wir das ganze gut umgerührt
sobald man alles gut miteinander
verrührt ist geben wir das hähnchen mit
hinein und auch noch die zwiebel denn
die gibt noch mal richtig leckeren
geschmack
und jetzt wird das ganze noch mal mit
wasser übergossen bis das hähnchen
komplett bedeckt ist
[Musik]
jetzt muss das ganze einmal aufkochen
und dann lass mich mit geschlossenem
deckel köcheln und zwar 30 bis 45
minuten es kommt immer darauf an wie
groß ein hähnchen ist und wann es dann
eben gar ist 45 minuten bin jetzt um und
das hähnchen ist gar und jetzt holen wir
es aus dem sud und ihr dürft dass hühner
so nicht wegschmeißen denn daraus könnt
ihr jetzt ein richtig leckere suppe
kochen
[Musik]
außerdem brauchen wir nachher noch etwas
von dem hühner sieht für unser hähnchen
und das dass ich jetzt erstmal zehn 15
minuten stehen damit wir uns auch gleich
nicht die finger verbrennen fette dort
wird traditionell mit frittiertem
libanesischen fladenbrot angerichtet
hieß das ganze vorbereitet
ich zeige euch jetzt aber wie ihr das
ganz einfach selber machen könnt wir
haben hier dieses libanesische plan wo
das findet ihr in jedem arabischen oder
türkischen supermarkt und das müssen wir
jetzt einmal in der hälfte durch teilen
dann erhaltet ihr zwei richtig dünne
brote so und diese boote nicht jeder
einfach übereinander schneidet sie in
kleine quadrat und dann werden sie ganz
kurz kritisiert
und die boote werden jetzt in neutralem
öl frittiert zb sonnenblumen oder rapsöl
und das dauert auch wirklich nur 30
sekunden sind sie schön goldbraun dann
nimmt er sie raus und lasst ihr auf
einem küchentuch abtropfen
bevor es jetzt weitergeht mit unserem
hähnchen müssen wir zuallererst die haut
entfernen und es dann zu rufen und
anschließend zeige ich euch die weiteren
zutaten
sobald ihr dann das hündchen gut zu ruft
habt geht es weiter mit dem nächsten
zutaten
ich hab euch vorhin schon gesagt dass
ihr von dem hinter sucht etwas zur seite
stellen müsst den rest könnt ihr gerne
zur suppe weiter verarbeiten das macht
meine schwiegermama auch gerade
und wir benötigen knoblauch etwas
sesampaste zitronen oder limettensaft
[Musik]
so die knoblauchzehe habe ich jetzt fein
gepresst oder geschnitten besser gesagt
und gibt es jetzt mittags so drehe ich
genau das wollte hat mir gefehlt dann
geben wir sesampaste also termine mit
dazu das findet ihr in jedem türkischen
oder arabischen supermarkt und china mit
ok jetzt sehen wir als nächstes geben
wir damit dazu dass es sesampaste und
die findet in jedem türkischen oder
arabischen supermarkt
[Musik]
der hühnersuppe es drin und gibt da am
besten aber erst ein bisschen mithin
zuschaut wie die konsistenz ist und man
könnte ja nach nennen immer noch ein
bisschen mehr dazu geben jetzt presse
ich noch den dementen saft aus ich nehme
hier auch erst mal eine halbe und schaut
dann einfach ob es mir sauer genug ist
oder nicht schaut einfach mal was euch
am besten gefällt
zu guter letzt dem wir noch eine gute
prise thymian mit hinzu und dann ist der
teil auch schon fertig so schade genau
auf arabisch jetzt habe ich mir gerade
noch mal rat von der chefin geholt und
sie sagte auf jeden fall noch mal ein
bisschen mehr dazu geben so dass es
schon ein bisschen flüsse von der brühe
[Musik]
wir benötigen außerdem zum schichten
noch kichererbsen hier habt jetzt zwei
möglichkeiten entweder indem sie rund
acht stunden im wasser ein und kocht sie
dann für eine stunde mit backpulver ich
habe euch das mit dem humus video schon
gezeigt wenn das spiel gemacht dass hier
auch so vorbereitet oder aber ihr nehmt
kichererbsen aus der dose
sie sind vor gegart und dann müssen sie
nur noch 5 minuten kochen und dann
werden sie auch schön weich ich habe
jetzt hier wie gesagt dass wenn man dass
schwiegermama wird das noch einmal kurz
erwärmen und dann geht es weiter
hier genau aber das kannst du auch
zeigen denn wir werden hier heute reist
dazu servieren
und genau das ist der reiz und eintopf
weiter ist die suppe und zwar aus dem
hühner sucht was wir übrig haben hier
gibt ihr einfach gemüse eurer wahl rein
um das so lange köcheln bis es gar ist
jetzt können wir endlich herbst beginnen
[Musik]
den bodenbelägen wir jetzt mit den
gebratenen brotstückchen darüber
verteilen wir jetzt unser hähnchen und
ich habe hier sehr viel flüssigkeit
meine schwiegermama hat es mir so
geraten aber sie sagte noch den hinweis
dass wenn ihr nicht so viel flüssigkeit
haben möchtet dann könnt ihr das auch
einfach abschöpfen und drinnen lassen
dass es gar kein problem ganz genau
[Musik]
als nächstes gehen wir unsere
kichererbsen darüber und die hier hat
noch ein bisschen flüssigkeit so ist es
eben nicht ganz so trocken und ich
bewahre mir aber auch noch ein bisschen
von den kichererbsen so gerade so drei
vier esslöffel für die deko später auf
[Musik]
sobald die kichererbsen schicht auch
drauf ist vorteil dass es so gerne zu
weichen mit dem löffel aber nur so ganz
grob es muss nicht vollkommen
miteinander vermischt sein
so als nächstes nehmen wir unsern
joghurt ihr habt ja schon erwähnt dass
sich etwas getrocknete münchen zugegeben
habe seit das in der regel nicht nötig
dafür ihr habt einen ganzen satz schon
im fleisch haben und zwar ruhig das
kurzen gibt das noch mal drüber
ja es liegt auch viel auf dem spiel
gleich werden sechs personen hier von
essen
[Musik]
und anschließend zeige ich euch wie ich
das ganze dekoriere auf nüsse will ich
nicht verzichten die vorher in der
fettfreien von einfach anrösten und ihr
könnt auch gerne petersilie dazugeben
dann habt ihr noch mal diesen
farbwechsel dieses grüne finde ich auch
super schön
ihr könnt auch gerne noch olivenöl dazu
nehmen das mache ich auch ist aber auch
wirklich geschmackssache
[Musik]
am besten serviert ihr vetter george
direkt das heißt ihr bereitet das zu
schichtet das ganze und dann verzerrt er
das sofort damit das brot auch nicht
weich wird ich finde es unglaublich
lecker aber das persönlich zum ersten
mal hier bei meiner schwiegerfamilie
probiert und ich sage euch wenn ihr das
austesten dann genießt es ihr werdet es
nicht bereuen und ihr werdet ist mit
duncan glaubt die süße zeug wirklich so
und ich schreibe die man dazu schreibt
ihr immer die genauen mengenangaben
unten in die infobox schotter gerne rein
macht euch die screenshots geht
einkaufen und bereitet das ganze zu
schickt mir eure fotos mit dem hashtag s
kitchen über instagram und ansonsten
wünsche ich euch einen ganz guten
appetit wird zwar noch was sagen haben
sie das nicht ganz bei dir zu hause
alles klar ihr lieben ich freue mich
aufs nächste mal tschüss
[Musik]